i remember having this thought when you
and i were in the battle of ramadi
and that thought was
how freaking awesome
the u.s military was
and how much of that awesomeness relied
on these individual human beings
that were making things happen
because when you look at
the operations that were taking place
when you look at the effort that was put
forth
it was literally
platoon commanders company commanders
battalion commanders brigade commander
that was
that was through force of will
making things happen
making things happen you could if if if
the brigade commander
didn't really care and just wanted to
kind of do a deployment get it under his
belt and just like uh yeah i did my
deployment
if he didn't care
if he didn't want to do good
we wouldn't have done anything yeah
right the battalion commander that's
going to push into an area of operations
that hasn't been pushed
there is individual effort
and here's what's scary
is
look in the battle of ramadi we were
trying to
we're trying to stabilize and secure the
city of ramadi
if there's no goal like that a clearly
defined goal and you have people that
are
trying to do make their best individual
effort to make their mark to leave their
mark to do something to get a good fit
rep
what are you going to do
you're going to say well
we're going to do this we're gonna do
that we're gonna expand we're gonna grow
more i need more people
this idea that there's no real competing
competing um
asset or competing competing uh
perspective of someone that's saying hey
wait a second
what are you actually doing over there
i mean if let's say
you went you were you were in the marine
corps
and you were supposed to train iraqi
soldiers
and
i do turn over with you and you say yup
hey jocko we trained 100 iraqi soldiers
and i go that's great how many iraqi
soldiers do you think i'm going to train
how many think 101 at least 101 at least
101 yeah i'm gonna do more than you
totally
i'm gonna do more new i remember this is
back in the day i remember going out on
uh um
workups with the with the fleet
and you could
see i did a workup with the fleet that
was i wasn't i wasn't embarked but we
did some work with the marines
then my next deployment i did a full
workup with the marines then the next
one i did another full workup with the
marines so i did basically saw three
workups in a row with the marines and
each one of them was a little bit more
each workup was a little bit more sure
hey oh yeah you guys did you guys did
four amphibious landings oh yeah i'm
gonna do five we did five yeah oh what
about the next one with the next guys
doing six
this is real yeah
i had similar experience and even in
training uh you know
classic question is the outgoing
squadron versus the incoming squadron
how many pounds of horns did you drop
you know 74
what we're talking about here which is
no admiral goes you know what i think we
need less ships
the amount of admirals that say that is
zero total the amount of generals that
say i need less divisions i need less
brigades i need less battalions the
number of generals that say that is zero
or you know sure are there some i'm sure
there are but the vast majority and
those those few that say well i think we
need less ships
he's not getting he's definitely not
getting promoted
to the cno yeah he's definitely not
gonna be the cno hey i'm the guy that
downsized the navy promote me it's not
happening right it's not happening hey i
got us less brigades less combat
brigades good job yeah let's promote you
no one says that
so you have this self-fulfilling
prophecy and this self-licking ice cream
cone which is a term i understand what
it means but i'm not exactly sure
you know where it came from right but
that's what you have right is we want to
have more and that's exactly what he's
talking about here
there was no one
there was very few people
that would come back and say hey uh yeah
the iraqi soldiers we had to do it in
ramadi we had to say these guys are not
ready yet
because it was it was so obvious what
would happen if we just sent them out on
their own and they tried i mean remember
they turned over like some of the
checkpoints like two nine or five and
uh they turned it over and and two days
later the insurgents hit it and overrun
it uh ecp three down there by on the
bridge
same thing turned it over to the iraqis
hey these guys are ready you know it's
like actually no they weren't ready and
they got annihilated
so that wasn't really the the
opportunity for us to be like well yeah
the iraqi troops that we are trained are
now 100
what do they call it what they call it
they're ready for unilateral operations
right
i didn't send up a message saying yep
our iraqis that we've been training for
six months are now ready for unilateral
operations even though that was what
everybody wanted us to say but we
couldn't say it there because you would
find out on their first operation that
there is no possible way they were ready
but if we would have been a more
permissive environment the pressure to
say
yeah hey they can conduct unilateral and
unilateral operations the pressure would
have been so great because otherwise be
like hey jocko the last the last uh task
unit commander that's out here has you
know he trained up four platoon special
mission unit elements that are now that
were now ready to perform unilateral
operations what did you do i'd be like
well actually i don't think those four
are even capable and we should downgrade
them
well what's wrong with you jocko the
last task unit commander was able to is
why couldn't you do that
so you felt that pressure and a lot of
times people break to that pressure i
mean obviously i think that happened a
lot in afghanistan
yeah hey we trained these guys for six
months
and who says yeah we trained somebody
for six months they're not capable we
train them for a year they're not
capable it's difficult it's a difficult
thing to do it's also difficult to
assess
so i think you get this that's what he's
talking about here there's no no admiral
wants to be without a ship no general
wants to be out of
command so what do they do they want
more